you've said that if you do cyber crime
eventually it's not going to end well it
does not end well why is that
so I don't want to say that's because
you're going to be arrested because
honestly very few people are arrested
all right but it doesn't end well
because of the type of person that that
you become I you you quoted me earlier
you you lie
to everybody around you you lie to
yourself you lie to your friends you lie
to your family of course you lie to your
victims you don't have any friends
you know I went 20 years
without friends I had Associates I
didn't have friends
um and you can't truly trust me you
don't trust anybody you don't trust
anybody you know I had uh my wife I was
married for nine years
I lied to her every single day of those
nine years
and it took her nine years to uh to give
up on me to realize that I was that
piece of [ __ ]
and uh she leaves at that point then
from there I started dating a stripper
and lied to her lied I thought I had
friends I lied to all those people that
I knew that thought they were my friends
I lied to them the entire time you
become that individual I don't think a
lot of people really understand
how bad that is you know you talked
about you you pointed out that woman
that I ripped off she was trying to put
a a roof on her house for freaking kids
man you're that person you're that
person so you're also lying to yourself
and that's not a mindset in which you
can
grow as a person
find happiness find genuine simple human
affection which is what love is yeah
simple real friendship all of those
things right so I you know I went to
prison of course one of the things one
of the most important lessons I that
I've learned in prison
because cyber crime crime as a whole if
you're a criminal it's an addiction all
right if you're addicted to something
whether it be drugs crime gambling what
have you if you're addicted to something
you cannot love anything else except the
addiction the addiction comes first all
right and you know you pointed out some
of those
truly despicable things
script for example tortures that guy you
get to the point where it's like okay
this is the business and you know I
tried to convince myself that uh you
know I'm a businessman but I'm a good
guy on the other end and you're not
you're not so those lies become part of
it everything else and uh
you know it's yeah you get the
higher-ups are usually arrested they are
but you know you've got millions of
cyber criminals these days so most guys
are not going to be arrested so you may
be arrested you may
um you may be like freaking Jonathan
James he was a minor a very very
talented individual uh very competent he
had uh as a kid he had broken into NASA
DOD Pentagon he shut the NASA computers
down for six weeks this is that kid uh
then he decides he wants to go into
credit card theft partners with Albert
he's arrested with Albert
um law enforcement
they were going on they were going to
blame him he was the only competent
individual
so this kid gets up one day he wasn't in
prison yet he gets up one day goes in
his dad's bedroom gets out his 45.
walks in the bathroom and blows his
brains out
you know you've got you've got things
like that
um or you're going to rip somebody off
and you're gonna end up like scripted
with that guy the uh the guy who hit uh
who ran Evolution Marketplace no wonder
who two people around that guy and a
girl
and no wonder who they were
he ends up stealing about 24 million
dollars a lot of from Ukrainian mob and
they found him about a year later on a
beach without his head and hands but uh
you know it always goes south but more
than anything to me the uh
the negative thing is is you really
become somebody
that I mean just truly a despicable
human being when you get to the point
when you're you're still you're
destroying people's retirement accounts
you're stealing money from a woman that
simply wants to do something good for
her family when you when you become that
individual and you're okay with that my
God man I got to the point I had one guy
I ripped off
it's like for 900 since when I first
started the cyber crime stuff it's when
I was becoming competent and uh I ripped
them out for like 900 and he sent me an
email and uh he was like uh I the email
said something like uh
I guess you needed the money
and it's okay you know you keep it and
uh I hope I'm getting chills right now
thinking about it but it's that uh
before you become that individual
wow yeah